:musique des vidéos de Nozman:
Wouaw.
Pourquoi cet objet tourne ?
Eh bien, en donnant une impulsion
Il va tourner sur lui-même ce qui fait que la force centrifuge va
OH C'EST FAUX c'est pas une vidéo de Nozman !
Je t'aime Nozman ! :bisous: J't'aime.
Aujourd'hui on va pas parler sciences, on va parler, on va faire un truc beaucoup plus con. *rire*
Mais qui plairait quand-même à Docteur Nozman !
On est sur un jeu qui s'appelle Hidden Folks et c'est l'un des premiers jeux auxquels t'as joué dans ta vie.
Eh oui même si tu le sais pas encore, c'est le jeu où tu as un dessin immense et il faut trouver certains éléments dans le dessin.
Voilà y'a un jeu vidéo qui est sorti, c'est sur ça.
Oui j'ai 7 ans et demi dans ma tête et alors?
J'y ai pas encore joué, j'voulais attendre cette vidéo pour y jouer, si ça se trouve c'est de la merde. :rire:
Si ça se trouve ça pue la merde. A mon avis ça pue pas la merde et surtout l'évolution va être ouf genre là
au début c'est un tout petit dessin. Donc j'pense qu'à la fin ça va être un dessin immense,
on va passer 8 ans et demi dessus pour trouver un putain de serpent ! Ca va être la merde.
Comment ça marche ? On a un dessin, ici on a les 3 éléments qu'on doit trouver.
Et y'a... y'a vraiment un putain de serpent à trouver ! :rire: Meeeec
Et là "Kiki le singe aime les abris bien douillets". Kiki c'est un prénom de chien, ce singe doit être malheureux à partir de là.
Déjà là ! Voilà c'est lui il est là
Nan c'est pas lui ? Ah nan c'est pas lui !
Putain y'a plusieurs singes ! Mais comment je reconnais Kiki des autres ?
Il aime les abris bien douillets. A partir de là il est où Kiki ? Où y'a un abri bien douillet ?
Là ! :bruitage du jeu tu du: C'est lui. C'est Kiki le siiiiiiinge !
Et bien bravo à tous n'est-ce pas bien sûr c'est... :applaudissements:
Il se passe un truc.
Alors, euh, ce gros serpent rampe dans les buissons
Bah des buissons y en a pas partout hein, heuuum
Et je trouve quand même pas ! Je pue la merde !
Il n'y a pas de buisson, p*tain, il n'y a pas de p*tain de ... Ça !
Ehh oh oh, déjà tu te calmes l'arbre okay ? Attends oh
Ça c'est des buissons
Banane blanche
Ah fallait trouver banane blanche, que j'ai trouvé
Nickel, c'était prévu c'était fait exprès
* Pling ! *
* SSssss *
Bah j- je  je sais m- je sais même pas où il était
Entre dans la jungle, alors mec ça va être OOWW ! what the fuck ?!
* rigole *
On en a pour mille ans ! J'peux zoomer ?
Ouais j'peux zoomer
Oh la la mais mec, non mais on en parle de la difficulté
On va jouer à un jeu, résout ce calcul
Tu as trouvé, 4, c'est ça
Maintenant un peu plus dur, résout ce calcul là
Alors ?
Mec c'est abusé, vraiment c'est abusé
Ça n'a pas de sens de faire ça, enfin, vraiment
L'assise inconfortable est le dernier des soucis
Déjà c'est un mec comme ça, donc c'est lui, c'est lui
Je me sens frais et tout !
okay il y en a un deuxième, si tu veux l'avis Jessy la Classe, les siestes en haut d'un arbre c'est ce qu'il y a de mieux !
Donc c'est un mec qui dort en haut d'un arbre.
Il est pas en haut d'un arbre
Bah si !
Ah c'est des arbres ça, d'accord !
J'avais pas calé
Excuse moi, c'est que chuis tellement fort en dessin
que quand c'est pas assez bien fait j'arrive pas à voir, enfin c'est ...
WHO ! J'ai trouvé un panda sans faire exprès, c'est énorme, ça m'arrive tous les jours, des fois je tombe sur un panda, chais pas comment je fais
Ils cachent des trucs derrières les arbres mec, c'est tellement des fourbes !
Chuis obligé de détruire l'environnement, juste pour trouver des gens, c'est incroyable !
Et le singe volant !
En fait je clique sur des trucs, j'ai même pas besoin de voir les noms
J'pense qu'on va procéder comme ça, ce sera plus simple
Nouvelle zone débloquée !
Ah, là on va pouvoir y aller en profondeur
La guitare est en pleine conversation avec la balançoire.
Bah, elle est là !
Près de l'arbre et de la ...
Ouais !
La meuf avec sa canne...
Bah elle est derrière les plantes là, ouais
La meuf allongée elle est là-dedans
Nan
Elle est dans une tente ?
Voilà, probablement ici.
Et ça c'est quoi ?
Sa brosse à cheveux
QUOI ?! Elle était dans un trou mec !
N'importe quoi, ça n'a aucun sens !
Oh bord*l de m*rde !
* Inspire bruyamment *
Mais mec !!
Mais j'en ai pour 8 années !
C'est bon ! Cette vidéo va durer 10 heures, vraiment
Alors y'a quoi ? Y'a un apiculteur
Mai qui joue avec des papillons
Au lieu de jouer avec une arme qui glace les gens ...
Énorme, vous avez compris ?
Mai, Overwatch, c'est énorme, on est dans le futur
Une banane, une truffe, un lapin qui est caché dans un trou ... Où il y a des abeilles ?
Ça c'est le coin des abeilles, c'est des ruches. Donc ici logiquement il doit y avoir ...
Lui là !
L'apiculteur !
C'est lui.
YES ! On a trouvé l'apiculteur, c'est énorme
Okay, ensuite elle, elle joue avec des papillons. Avec des papillons ... Là il y a des papillons
Elle doit être ... Là !
Oui c'est le bûcheron, bien sûr
Bien sûr, c'est lui qu'on cherchait, c'était pas du tout la meuf qui cherchait les papillons, n'importe quoi
Mec, c'est dur
Est-ce que vous voyez des papillons quelque part ?
Dites moi.
Tweetez le moi.
Oh la la mais ça va loin !
Ah, ici, bah voilà.
Ici c'est le coin à papillon
Énorme !
Le mec il dézoome, il a direct repéré les papis et tout, comme on les appelle
Okay, il reste Pikachu, il est à côté du seul point Hi-Fi du camping
Le seul point Hi-Fi du camping, mec c'est ...
* Bruitage étrange et dérangeant *
Faut plus, ce bruitage, plus jamais
Ah, c'est là où il y a des enceintes et tout, c'est sûr c'est là, mec c'est sûr c'est là
On va ouvrir toutes les tentes, je m'en bas les couilles je réveille les gens !
Je veux trouver Pikachu !
WOUW !
Un fermier, une fourche et une fleur rare.
Okay, facile.
Hop la !
La fleur rare elle est là !
Le fermier,
il manque juste la fourche.
Où est la fourche ?
Alors là mec, la fourche, il y a un vrai délire là
Sous le truc de p*tain !
Okay est-ce que vous êtes prêts pour une nouvelle mission extraordinaire ?
Alors c'est parti mon pote, je met mes lunettes de hacker, chais pas pourquoi.
P*tain mec, c'est le pire jeu pour mettre des lunettes, du coup je vois rien, c'est terrible !
Un antique esprit natif Américain a soudainement pris possession d'Awan le garde-forestier.
Qu'est ce que ça veut dire ?
Qu'est ce que tu fais quand un antique esprit natif Américain prend possession de ton corps ?
Ah p*tain, c'est un indice mais je saurais pas le décrypter, chuis une m*rde
Il est temps de faire rentrer dans la tête de Newton de la physique qui porte ses fruits ...
Okay !
D'après Harry, du bétail invisible est toujours du bétail.
Aiguille n'est pas dans une botte de foin, mais elle sait comment on roule.
* Intense réflexion *
Okay !
Ensuite on a : un cadavre de poisson, un taureau, un épouvantail en haut de forme
Et Chuck le poulet.
Mec, alors déjà, c'est ... au revoir
C'est parti !
Okay, l'épouvantail !
Fallait faire pousser du blé pour qu'il apparaisse, excellent
Okay le taureau, qui était dans un enclos.
Désolé j'ai même pas le temps de vous prévenir,
parce que je clique sans savoir si ça va être ça ou pas
Eh attends mec, moi je veux retrouver ce p*tain de... de... de poulet qui s'est enfui là !
Son enclos il est là, il peut pas être bien loin ce p*tain de poulet ... Il est où ce poulet ?
Il disent qu'il est allé ... là !
YES !
Derrière le buisson p*tain, vous l'avez pas vu !
* Cherche désespérément *
Et voilà les gens, c'est déjà la fin de cette vidéo, j'espère qu'elle vous a plu, si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à l'aimer comme d'habitude
Mec, c'est sérieux d'avoir une map aussi grande,
J'peux pas plus dézoomer, c'est horrible !
Chef Toto était encore debout une minute plus tôt.
Okay, il y a un indien qui va mal à trouver
Le mec qui veut aller au festival mais les panneaux ne l'aident pas.
Aladdin qui surfe sur les vents légers à travers le désert, un cactus, une plante,
une lunette, de la femme que les trois vautours n'ont pas mangé.
Oh la la ...
Okay, bon, c'est parti !
J'te jure que j'en ai pour la nuit mec, je veux au moins trouver le cactus,
parce que je sens qu'y a un cactus qui a un chapeau, c'est super cool.
Il est où le cactus ?
Putain j'ai envie de me flinguer
* Éternuement *
Même mon corps fait une allergie là !
* Et de deux *
P*tain !
Si quelqu'un,
a vu le cactus qu'avait un chapeau et ne me l'a pas dit,
Alors là je vais lui en vouloir à tout jamais, je... j'préfaire vous prévenir hein
P*tain mec, c'est la plus grosse enquête de ma life
Je prend ce jeu beaucoup trop au sérieux, comme tous les jeux auxquels je joue en ce moment
Je n'accepterai jamais d'échouer à cette épreuve et de voir derrière des gens qui prennent des screens de la vidéo
et qui entoure, tu sais, l'objet que j'ai pas vu pendant que je tournais
Mais regarde, il était là le cactus !
Ce scénario n'arrivera jamais parce que je vais me battre et je vais try hard
* musique épique *
* musique épique bis *
WOOAAWH !!
Hop la, ouiii !
I am so f*cking happy
Eh ben les amis cette fois c'est vraiment la fin de la vidéo, n'hésitez pas à l'aimer si elle vous a plu
Les "Où est Charlie" et comme ça c'est pour moi indémodable, c'est trop bien
Par contre, tu te prends tellement d'infos à la seconde que t’arrive même plus à voir des trucs basiques !
C'est trop cool, j'suis content d'avoir joué à ce jeu avec vous,
comme si on avait cinq ans et demi, finalement, et qu'on faisait une petite pyjama-party ...
C'est beau.
Allez les amis à très vite dans une prochaine vidéo et n'oubliez pas :
en faisant ceci on crée une poussée,
l'objet de cette manière va réagir en faisant ...
Arrête Nozman !
À toi qui lit ces sous-titres, passe une bonne journée ;)